this is certain sentiment among women sometimes like oh
I'm not like other girls
I can do all these things
when it's like that in and of itself is like
slightly misogynistic and a real pick me girl spirit
like it's totally okay to be like other women
other women know how to change a tire too
other women you know
fucking drink beer and watch baseball or football
or whatever the fuck it is that you're into that you think it's like
I'm not like other girls
I would pick the man
I wouldn't pick the bear
like shut the fuck up okay
you're so fucking unique and cool
like is that what you wanted
it just it breaks down the camaraderie that women can build
when you have to be different and better than other women
like just sit the fuck down
we're just can we all just fucking vibe
can we fucking vibe